Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to POPGOES! Now we're gonna roll right back into it and not do the thing that
we did and caused us to be dead which is run out of sanity, or whatever the "Panic Meter" is, it's just basically sanity, right?
So it's a mechanic by which I go crazy, or they kill me, because I panic, and my brain explodes out of my ears.
So anyway, I got a few things to look out for-I think...
I think the... the-the-the-
animatromos with the signs. They're caused by me panicking-it's not necessarily that anything's happening here, right?
I'll see you then I guess... guess you'll be on your way-I'll find out the answers to all my questions later. (To ringing phone) What? What IS IT?
What is it? I gotta pay attention to this guy...
Fritz: Right! Hey again. Second night. Hope you've gotten used to your job by now,
pressing buttons on a phone...
You'll have trouble finding a job that actually requires you to be on one of those...
Mark: Where'd he go?
Fritz: Anyway, I expect efficient use of that phone, okay?
Mark: Oh, he's still there
Fritz: Oh, and I'll let you know now, don't start slacking off, I'm paying attention. After your first week is done-(Mark cuts him off) Shut up!
Why is he still there... WHY'S HE STILL THERE?!?!?
HAH?!?
Why you still there? What are you doing still there?
What are you doing a whole bunch of still there?
I don't like how much you're stiAAHH he's gone. Did he go? Or did he not go? I don't know what you did, you didn't go.
Didn't go anywhere, it's this
goddamn rota-ooOOOH!
Oh you're gone now-Damnit you're playing with my emotions like that, SHUT DOWN!
And vent, and heat-For some reason, I don't know whyy, I don't know why I need alot of heat (Sing-song voice), but I do-
Apparently. I don't know why... I think he's still there
Why am I heating you?
Why am I heating you? I don't know-I dont understand the mechanics-hhEEYYAHHEHY-
YEYAHEYEYHEAYEY!
aaEEYAY!
Don't do that. Don't do that to that (French accent?)! Don't do that to nobody. Imma heat, I guess...
'Don't know whyy... (Kinda sing-songy)
Also I don't know what the noises are, so imuna-imuna hold off on the heat because I dont know if I'm doing
anything detrimental to myself.
Man, this guy is... This guy is more persistent about 3D-printing this Shadow Bwonnie...
And if you get that Shadow Bwonnie
He's gonna be on my butt in a second or two, so..
Gotta do this...
I heard a balooda-loop.
I don't know what the balooda-loop is,
But oh... Oh-
WHAT THE FACK ARE YOU?
WHAT WAS THAT?!?!
OH THAT'S NOT GOOD-
I'M IN trouBULLLL!
Uh-oh
Uhp-? No-?
Heat? Do I need heat?
Is that what I need? I thinkga-Oh, you should panic, really, should I? I think I'm already in troubbllle-What was that?
Thought I saw something...
Okay... I don't know whats going on here, 'cuz THAT was weird...
That was rather peculiar-I dont know what I just SAW!
The hecky heck is going hecking ON here?
Whoa?
Anybody... HOOOME? Oh there you are okay, okay there you go alright you shut down..
Don't know what the heat do...
I don't know what noises im listening out for!
hEEEAT ME-
HEAT ME!
Give me heat!
Oh you're still there. Okay, alright...
(Pop) Pop!
Okay "Pop goes the weasel". Pop goes the markimoo when he SQUEEZES my brains out...
OH HOW'D YOU GET A PIECE? OH HOW'D YOU BREAK OFF A PIECE OF THAT BULLSHIT? Oh frick you, dude.
Wah.
Oop, he moved!
He's a mobile little son of awee-There he is. Well it was hard to see you! Not quite as hard as me seeing me!
What are you two gonna do back there? I know that you two have-woo...
...I know that you two have somethin' to do with all this but I dooh-whoa what the fuck he was right-there-he-was-right-ther-
-he-was-right-here-he-was-righ-there-whered-he-go-whered-he-go-AWW GOD DAMNIT THE LAST ONE
All right. Everything's hunky-dickie. If I can just get... My ass out of my ass I should be fine to get through this.
Well panic-inducing! It's a little when I don't know the god damn mechanics of you-
So where did that asshole come from? Where did the mechanical bullshit-asshole go?
What was that?
Why do I need to check these-uh-
More room m-more-more noises happen-wait a minute....
There you are! NO-
Not today-
Seems to be more nnoises-WAIT A MINUTE WHERE ARE YOU GOING?!?!?
WHY'RE YOU GOING TO THE STAFF ROOM?!?!
NO-
NO THATS BAD-
WHYSU-STAFF ROOM?!?!
HOW DO I SHUT YOU-
GET SOME COLORS IN YE BITCH!
WHHAH!
nOOO DON'T GO IN THE VENT-
NO NO NO NO HEAT! I DO-I THINK-I DO- OOH IM DEAD AREN'T I? I'M- I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BEAT THIS-
I DONT KNOW WHAT
YOU WANT FROM ME! Oh you stop that-
So they're good-uh ohuhuhoh you are too la-I DONT KNOW-WEHHH- AM I REALLY?
IS IT REALLY TO LLAAEE-
HEEAAAT-
I've got heat for youuu!
His name is Fritz-I don't care I am panicking AUGH!
Its hard to see when im PANICKING...
Got all this panic juice shooting out of my eyes
I'm gonna heat a vent again I think-euh... It went in the vent... They're in the..woo...They're in the vent..
They're not-they didn't just GO in the vent they're IN the vent...
I am in the FUCK. I am in the
BONE ZONE!
I'm in the ZONE of BONE!
YEEEEEET
YEET! I'm gonna DIE!
Shut-I didn't mean to do that but I'll heat it up anyway! Fine if I'm gonna make bullshit and mistakes I might as well make 'em all
How did he get another ppieeeeeece?
How did he get another piece of pOOzle?
I don't know how to get another piece of the pOOzle.
I'm gonna heat SOMEthin'.
Oh no you dont.
Eugh. I think I'm doing the right thing, I'm not 100 percent sure but I think I am...
If I'm not then I'm gonna-g-thuh-die. That's just the long of the short of it I'm gonna die.
Okay im gonnajuayh-
OH! I SEE YOUUuuUUUUU!
Oh I caught you question mark? I he-heated you ooauughh I am here great-good-
(Sarcasm) GOOD for you!
You're here oh give a round of applause  to Mr. Here-man
S-s-what was all thaat?
Wuh-wuhya doin up there? Why are you up there? Th-that don't make NO sense-
Ah shit-shit-
(Groan)
So they're like at the far vent is that what that thing is and they gotta
make their all the way to me is that-is that what they dooo??
Is that the do that they are? Is that the dooo?
So what do they? Because if that what they doo then-rfheyeahurrgr-I'm SKWOOD!
Don't like it.
Why-Okay I guess I'm just relaxed instantaneously. I go from a full NOT relaxed to a full relaxed.
Oh-
AWH they're not there anymore they're THERE! I need to give THEM some heat but I FUCKED it. Oh YOU'RE not gonna FUCK IT-
Is that what you're makin' that Shadow Bonnie? Some kindaaa... Weirdo-real-life doll?
Not into that-HEEEEAT! Take my HEEEAT!
I'M GONNA BANISH YOU WITH THE POWER OF MY HEEEAT! I think-I don't know
Kinda just grasping straws right now
HEEEEAT!
TAKE MY HEEAT N'
COLORS! ALL THIS AND A LITTLE POP AND A BOINK!
THAT DO ANYTHING FOR YAA?
Good? Bad? Give me a review on Yelp!-Oh you'll kill me oh okay great well whatever. Well- this seems
to have stopped them pretty goood-
Pretty sure anyway. So now it's just about bouncing between the two of them
And then I'm good, right?
If that's all there is then I think I'm in the golden...
-Golden Freddy-
And whatever the hell that animatromo was-5 A.M..
Which bodes well for me-So what would I do if there was a-
They were already there? I'd be-I'd be fubbernucked like straight up. A million times.Through and through. (Checks vent) Still there okay their nice and toasty then they're real
Toasty
Really Toasty
Feel really toasty so you stay there you little kitties-You don't stay there you don't stay there-don't stay there and finish that-
Don't do that. That's not what you do.
You're still there you get heat-doink doink doink doink doink-BOINK!
And uh- I don't know I guess I'm almost outta here could this night be over sTOP THAT!
What wasthat...
You hearthat?
Heard that... Ooh...
Dont likkeey-I don't LIIIKEYY!
Cranky I don't like you.
So far so good-AM-I-GONNA-BE-DONE?
GIMME THE GODDAMN DONE! BOINKY BOINKY
GIMME THE BOINKY! AUGHH WHERE IS'E-
Where are you, you sack of shoot? Imuh stab you-with somthin-I don't know what but I'm gonna stab you.
oh STOP IT!
STOP IT!
stop it.
(Mark finishes the night; Pop Goes The Weasel 8-bit plays) OOOOOOOOOOOOOH!
(Markimoo dance of victory)
HEY!
WOO!
Okay anyway so I got that let's see what's goin' on in the next one...
I have a funny feeling that I'm not exactly...
You know, a willing participant in this experiment of ours
Oh...
What sortademon-what are you? I don't know what you are-I dont want
to know he's some kind of squirrel... He's all the other FNAF fan games in one horrible hell-hole
Why are we in a hellhole with veins and shit? And trash? And why was Balloon boy hooked up to that thing from Guardians of
The Galaxy two, and, you know having his soul all sucked out and such not... as that...
I'm trying to take a different path here maybe it's gonna lead to different results. thatde-OH!
That Foxy or is that Maanggllee?
Thah Mangles boowww?
Thata good ol' Mangle bow? I can't go this way apparently so I'm just gonna-
Don't like that sound... That's an un-
-comfortable sound...
What else is here is there just a whole other bunch of stuff waiting for me in the darkness?
Don't know, it's kind of a maze-Oh! A cupcake! Well this is where Chica's grave is but is it just like a-
Is it like a grave for all of them? Or not really a grave I guess if their all trapped in a part of a machineee...
Because they are all machines anyway so what does it matter?
You could NOT do that in my ear you could not raise the bass up please
Who is it-
Oh that's a microphone! Can I go this way Freddy? Fred boy? FRED BOY! Freddy?
Fre-woo
Freddy's tie and..
Hat
Well that spells bad...
Freddy? Are you hooked up to a giant tentacle machine?
I'm gonna close my eyes and i'm gonna walk in that room and if your in tentacles I'm gonna judge you-AHHHHW Im judging you okay
That's weird.
All right-
well-eh-OOOOHHHH
Third night with a BAAAANG alright let's get into this.
Don't know what new mechanic I'm gonna have to deal with but you're gonna tell me what it is and I'm gonna die...
Probably, I always do-Remember colors. Call the badger. THAT DOESNT MAKE ANY GODDAMN SENSE.
"Remember colors call the bAAdger" What does that even mean? What do you even mean? Who are you? Who am I? They're already goone-
Frick.
OH JEEZ PICK UP THE PHOONE!
F: Right (cough), hello again.
I think I should start off this call by pointing out that I actually made a mistake in my previous message
which was yesterday's main recording for you.
I said that the heaters in the vents stayed on for a minute when you turn them on.
In reality... I made it closer to like...
9 seconds or something so, uh, sorry about that.
M: GRREEEAT
F: Not a huge mistake but I should own up to it, anyway. It's one of the only things I haven't got written down.
I should actually make a note of it now, I suppose. (Papers being tampered with) I'm kinda tired right now; I've been doing all these calls in one take
so I've... just noticed it. Such a huge difference too, one minute should be ten seconds- Geez, I'm an idiot sometimes. (Fritz chuckles)
Hey, now that you've been here for... two nights, correct? Beginning your third one now, yeah?
M: Shit, they're already in the
F: Tell me, what do you think about the place? The pizzeria, I mean. It's real special.
M: HATE IT!
M: HOO IT'S REAL SPECIAL ALRIGHT
F: Let me tell you, during the day you can really feel it. The fantasy. The fun.
F: The safety, y'know? Kids can run down the halls and be greeted by the characters.
They gather around and sing with them on the stage, they... build and print out these... figurines, like posable toys.
And of course they get to paint them, coat them in binding agent, etc, makes them feel grown up.
M: Kay
F: And feel special, y'know?
F: I remember this kid one day.
Really heartwarming; there was this kid. He was running around and somehow managed to open one of the locked rooms.
The server room, I think it was. And he started messing around in there!
Well I was in my office, like always, and I see this kid on the camera.
I start to get a little worried. "Ah, here we go again," I'm saying to myself. And I was about to get him sorted out myself, but...
right then, as I'm taking my jacket off... Blake, that badger character to your left, gets in the room with the kid...
M: MY LEFT??!!
F: ...and starts to play a little game using the Server Room's monitor.
F: Have you...
Y'know... y'know the game "Simon Says"?
M: NO!
(Odd animatronic noises in the background) F: Well it was like that, he just turned the... o-oh...
Hold on now. I'll sort the rest out later.
I'll leave this message here; the options should be up to you now. Sorry about this. (Cuts off)
M: UHHH BADGER? WHAT IS SIMON SAYS? CAN YOU CONTINUE THE STORY?
F: Yes, yes, the story!  Sorry about before, I had to take care of something. Well I don't exactly remember where I left off, but the kid ended up liking Blake
quite a lot. The rest of the day, he just kept pressing his call button,
the yellow one to the left of the monitors, to get him to come closer and play their game.
It's moments like those that can make you smile, y'know?
Getting to use these characters to make people as happy as they've made me. It's... really something.
At least... I hope you feel the same way. I know you aren't here during the day, so I suppose you'll have to take my word for it
when I say it's great. And the kid I mentioned has been a loyal customer since...  ...Well, I don't really like using that word.
Mark: Hi? Oh?
F: See you tomorrow.
M: GOOH OH THATS A MOVIN' BADGER! OOOH THATS NO GOOD I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DOOO ABOUT THAT... I don't wanna doo about that! (Sing-song voice)
I'm gonna die- Oh you're really close!
Oh you're really close I don't know how to get rid of you
(More sing-song) I'm gonna die it's right behind me! Oh boy here we go death fine where'd he go all right it's gone
Well I'm fucked I'm really really fucked-oh shit-oh shit-I'm gonna be dead-
Ah fuck how do I-how does that-awie-aohwoo-je-How do you do this?!?
How do you do this-wuhjyu-Remember the colorss? Theres no colorrss!
Theres no-GET your hand back there!
Get your hand-Oh well shit what does that even mean?
Go well-all-well-I'm... I'm done, well and thoroughly boned-
WHAT DID I DO?!?!
I'm dead well obvious-obvious-ahh-dehh-duh-dead obviously-
OOOOhhh what was thaaat?
And why? And what happened?
I dont KNOOOOOW!
What happened? What happened. I don't know.
Anyway, thats all for this episode thank you everybody so much for watching I'm gonna continue this- It's getting TOUGH!
Tough, panic-inducing, all the above-
Welcome to WeaselWare indeed. So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think down the comments below!!
Now as always I will see you in the next video...
BUH-BYE!